earlier today
a man went to an fbi office in
cincinnati with a rifle and a nail gun
and he tried to i guess he tried to
breach the building he opened fire
they're saying in the direction of fbi
agents so it's hard to know uh exactly
how it all went down but we know that
after an alarm was set off he fled
ended up in a cornfield where he was
opening fire on police
the breaking news now is this man
is dead he was shot and killed after
about a five hour standoff now it's
being reported this man this man's name
is being reported um i'm not here to
shout his name out but we'll get into
the story because apparently he was on
truth social and he made a bunch of
posts talking about why he did what he
did
and
if this is the correct person who's
posting on truth social it was about the
fbi rate on donald trump so we got to
talk about that and then of course we
have merrick garland has come out and
stated that he signed off on the raid of
donald trump's home my opinion
revenge
of course he's pissed off conflict of
interest and this is the this is the
dangerous um
this is one of the dangers the problems
you have with weaponized and politicized
uh law enforcement so we're gonna talk
about that there's a lot of other
stories to go through i i'm proud to
state as much as i have my um qualms
with newsguard they have rated msnbc as
fake news finally
share that one with your family when
they're obsessed with it they tell you
you're wrong msnbc is true rachel maddow
blah blah blah yeah well newsguard says
fake news
before we get started my friends head
over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and pick up your
keto elevate c8 mct oil powder that's
medium chain triglyceride powder
and uh you know what i got the spiel and
i'll read some of it but i just got to
tell you guys have you noticed that
since the last year i've lost like 30
some odd pounds i've been doing keto i
have cut out all the sugar
i have a little bit of sugar but it went
from keto such as slightly low carb way
more fat way more protein way more
vegetables way less sugar and grains and
uh this keto elevate stuff really really
does help so again
eatrightandfeelwell.com
and you will get a 60 day money back
guarantee
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct that means it
provides support for energy levels
healthy appetite management mental
clarity and focus athletic performance
again i'm going to pause and just state
when i when i was eating you know all
the garbage
after dinner i'd i'd be falling asleep
and then i'd have to wake up before the
show come on
now i'm just like i feel like there's
energy running through my body
with uh biotrusts keto elevate you'll
get 5 grams of their highly sought after
mctc8
you'll get free shipping on every order
and for every order today biotrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year you'll get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free new e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order someone
else pointed out that that at the end of
the clips we do i'm like a little fatter
and i'm like yeah i've been losing
weight so we got to re-record our
close-out clip for the clips on this
channel because uh the keto stuff's
really been working so again
eatrightandfeelwell.com
and don't forget head over to
timcast.com to support our work directly
and check out our after hours uncensored
show monday through thursday at 11 p.m
we've had some pretty crazy
conversations this past week larry elder
was particularly interesting naomi wolfe
was very interesting last night
she mentioned that the government
actually was targeting her to get her
censored on social media platforms so
really crazy stuff plus as a member you
get access to all of our shows and soon
and because of all the members we will
have two documentaries launching really
great ones one's about gun control what
about the federal reserve we're also
working on a transhumanism documentary
but that's going to be coming in the
next phase so it is because you are
members we are able to produce these
documentaries and then we're going to
release them and members will be able to
watch them so i'm really excited for
that i think our timeline is the rough
is two and a half months from today
maybe it'll end up being a little bit
longer but i'm really excited for this
gun control documentary so don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share this show with your
friends joining us today to talk about
all of these issues is bethany mandel
hey thanks for having me would you like
to introduce yourself yes so i am uh the
editor of a children's book series
called heroes of liberty
and i am a columnist at deseret news and
a mom of five and a half
five and a half people yeah it's a half
person percolating a new person
making new people yeah oh glad to hear
you're watching it happening
on this show
right on well thanks for joining us yeah
we also have hannah claire bremelo hi
i'm hannah claire brimlow i'm a writer
for timcast.com now what is that site uh
it's this super cool kind of independent
news site we do
uh news on all kinds of things all kinds
of issues i post five times a day and i
think this is the longest my intro has
ever been oh very nice newsguard
certified which it is but not good
enough yeah that's so much 82 out of
100.
no but it is they posted a bunch of fake
news about us had to correct it refused
to issue proper corrections violating
their own policies and i take it very
seriously if they're going to claim usa
today which which admitted to
fabricating 23 sources in their stories
is more responsible than we are when
we've had one article out of 4 000 that
required a correction
that that they notice we've we issue
corrections all the time when we make
mistakes but they're like we noticed one
article so you're irresponsible get out
of here anyway ian's here oh yeah
anyway
um i decided to refresh last night i
took like an hour-long bath i was
telling you guys about it before the
show and instead of coffee today i'm
drinking coconut water i had a little
bit of aloe vera uh just the inner
fillet it's it's incredibly healing they
called it the flower i think the plant
of life the egyptians used to call it
that highly recommend get it on catch
you later let's do this yes let's do it
i'm loving how many ladies we have here
tonight you may notice i'm zoomed in a
little bit more than usual it's because
hannah claire is lovely and tall just
like me i kept getting the top of her
head in my shots i had to crop it out
i'm sorry hannah claire such a middle
child i need all the attention no no
it's fine it's all good i'm really
excited for tonight i love my ladies
let's get going all right here's the
first story from the daily mail armed
man who attacked fbi's ohio field office
is dead after five-hour standoff suspect
also attended deadly capital riot now
we don't know exactly to what extent he
was at the capitol riot i think that
maybe the daily mail is reporting
something different i've read a bunch of
other sources the new york times says
that he was there the night before but
he's not been charged with any crimes
but let's uh let's read see what they
say
ricky walter schiffer was shot dead by
police thursday after he raised a gun
towards officers around 3 p.m
state highway patrol confirmed schiffer
had attempted to break into the office
prompting a five-hour standoff with
authorities the body armor wearing
suspect fled the office and was chased
onto highway onto the highway man
copyeditor guys before abandoning his
car by a cornfield on a country road
just off of interstate 71 the
confrontation came as officials warned
of an increase in threats against
federal agents in the days following the
search a search of former president
donald trump's mar-a-lago estate in
florida investigators say schiffer was
also at the u.s capitol during the
january 6 insurrection they report
all right well they reported this stuff
i'm going to pull up some tweets that we
have
travis view says the new york times
identified the ohio shooting suspect as
ricky schiffer there is a truth social
account using that name on the same day
the fbi executed a warrant on mar-a-lago
the account made a call to be ready for
combat and i'm not going to read what he
said next but he called for extreme
violence wow
in the end
one of the last things he said
was that um yeah i can't i don't want to
i don't think we should read exactly
what he said
but he explained that he thought he had
a way to get through bulletproof glass
he was wrong he did not but this could
explain why it was reported that he
fired a nail gun at the at the fbi now i
read on nbc he fired at the agents but
perhaps they said towards them instead
of add was because there was bulletproof
glass he was not able to penetrate but
apparently this ricky schiffer guy on
truth social was saying that he did it
and if you don't hear form it's because
they got him or something to that effect
so um
i guess
my view on things obviously
george conway all right i'm gonna make
sure i cite george conway on this one
he said they crossed the rubicon
this is anti-trumper george conway they
crossed the rubicon which is an
insinuation that
a faction of people have crossed the
point of no return
towards what a civil war yeah but oh uh
there's nothing there's some random dude
that went crazy in my opinion no no no
no no no no he's he's talking about the
democrats and the fbi right
specifically so uh ian you you've you've
talked quite a bit about you know
ancient roman stuff like that the um
crossing of the rubicon yeah it was
forbidden in rome there was a river
right outside the city and if i get any
of this wrong just correct me in the
chat and i'd be happy to go over it
again but that it was illegal to ever
bring troops across the river into the
city of rome that was something they'd
all decided it was too dangerous so when
caesar was off on campaign he had you
know however many hundreds thousands of
troops that just basically worshipped
him and when he decided he came back to
rome he's like they were gonna try and
put him on trial to strip him of his
power and he was like you know what no i
want rome he crossed the rubicon he with
his troops took the city and they called
it forever known as the crossing of the
rubicon is when you've taken that step
the one step too far and that was the
that was the start of the civil war that
was basically the end of the roman
republic in the beginning of the empire
so
there was a leftist outlet that they
were like the far right is saying this
that or otherwise or something like that
and uh they said tim poole said they
crossed the rubicon and i'm like yeah
and so did george conway like this is
not a call to anything it's a statement
of it's an observation
i think they did yeah and uh first and
foremost obviously let me just say one
thing
this dude who went to the fbi field
office
must have really wanted democrats to win
because the i mean we're months out from
the midterm election and
surprisingly he did exactly what the
democrats needed he got violent failed
and now the democrats have their example
of what's wrong with the right that's
why
the craziest thing to me is like now is
the absolute worst time for anything
like that and this is why i say violence
doesn't work we are we are months away
from republicans taking the house and
the senate in what the misery index
predicts will be a crushing defeat
except now in the past few months
democrats have even doubted the polling
something like this happens i think
we're going to see democrats spiking in
the polls because of this yeah no i
agree i mean
this is this is the continuance of the
january 6th hysteria this is how they
continue that that line of conversation
but i i think that
we need to be a little bit careful and
you know knowing that this was the guy
because
i was trying to google which mass
shooting was it where it was the brother
that was identified and it went on for
hours and this guy like he was getting
calls do you remember was it newtown
i don't remember which shooting it was
but there was a there was a mass
shooting where the brother was falsely
identified um and so i would just you
know caution the expertise of whoever
this guy is with q and run like maybe
it's not him and maybe this guy well the
new york times said
oh well that's that's the right yeah
that's the beacon of truth and reality i
mean sure but i i guess the best thing
we can do is i mean i always just wait
24 hours right
fair point fair point and even if even
if it turns out that this is the guy i
don't think blaming a political party or
a movement or any of that makes any
sense because this guy just went off the
rails yeah i mean it's it's the same as
the baseball shooter
what's that the bait the congressional
baseball shooter that was never blamed
on democrats
um yeah it's a guy who uh
i think he was like even maybe a bernie
sanders supporter
he was he was a bernie sanders steve
scalise and like he opened fire at the
the congressional baseball practice
and almost killed steve scalise i mean
very few people know about it because it
was a story for like point three days
meanwhile january 6 we've been talking
about forever
but
i mean that was never that violence that
was never crossing the rubicon that was
never blamed on democrats it was just
like whoa it's just some crazy guy like
why this is just something this guy this
crazy guy right now i don't think is
crossing the is is a crossing of the
rubicon i think the weaponization of the
doj and garland being like yeah i signed
off on this is a crossing of the rubicon
yes and going into melania's closet yeah
i mean look we've talked about this when
trump was saying he would lock up
hillary everybody was like that would be
a dangerous time in this country and
then what did trump do he said we're not
going to go after early we're not going
to do it and everybody was disappointed
but trump was like no no you know we're
not going to do it and they didn't yeah
trump was standing at that river line he
was like no no that's too much it's too
much and public yep meanwhile hillary
has her
her but her emails hats she's
campaigning already or at least
fundraising go ahead i think i watched
merrick garland he did a speech today
the official like explanation they said
they're going to unseal the warrant to
explain why they uh invaded is that the
right word trump's house i don't know if
what the word is here rated rated they
said but don't call it a raid it was a
radio yeah i mean they went in there you
know unannounced um or maybe they
announced themselves right before they
went in well they did they went to the
lawyer they said get out we're gonna go
do our thing apparently they kept the uh
the cameras rolling so rubicon i don't
know jury's still out i want to see what
the warrant said maybe there is always
the possibility that trump was doing
something extremely nefarious and a
warrant wouldn't prove that
okay but would not you know a warrant is
their accusation yeah of pro or maybe
they have their wife
him and then they heard him say you know
no one we don't know i mean it's hard
not to view this as a complete fishing
expedition right they i mean why would
you write i'm sorry i'm sorry it's hard
not to view this as anything other than
fake
and weaponization why
because of russiagate because of ukraine
gate because we know they had fabricated
evidence and manipulated evidence
already so you know forgive me
hillary clinton's email server we looked
at they said well there's no criminal
intent fine
then they smear and lie about trump they
should have stopped the investigation
into russiagate long time ago yeah what
would have been a lawyer chain like
fabricated a a letter or something it's
been a while since i covered the story
but anyway sorry i digress oh all i was
going to say is that to me
this warrant you know we've heard the
story that there was a
a room that had a padlock on it that had
the documents that they're requesting
when you write a warrant you have to be
specific about what you're asking for so
theoretically garland signed off an
order that said we want complete and
unfettered access and we want the right
to not announce because we think that
they'll hide stuff
that to me indicates that it's a it's a
grab they want to see as get as much
stuff as possible and then maybe justify
it later when they're like oh but look
what we found when we showed up there
yeah in melania's closet there were all
these secret things that we knew about
so uh to understand what is it called
the fruit of the poisoned tree is that
what it's called yeah there's uh the
exclusionary rule yeah and this states
that um
if your rights are violated and evidence
is found that evidence is inadmissible
in court so there was one story i
remember reading about back in illinois
of a guy who had they thought he was a
murderer and so a cop ran his plates
pulled him over and then while he he he
said get out of the car illegally
searches the car finds evidence
sending the evidence turns out the stop
was illegal the lawyers get it thrown
out exclusionary rule you cannot use
evidence seized in violation of
someone's rights with this you get a
warrant for something like classified
documents
then once you're inside if you have a
warrant and you enter a home looking for
say classified documents and you find
pills and a gun
that's now admissible so anything they
found in the house perhaps this was a
fishing expedition and or trump's
suggesting they're planting evidence
that's a bold yeah that's the first
thing that crossed my mind when i heard
about this story what if they play like
how can you yeah confirm or deny if they
did that i mean i wouldn't put it past
them i was gonna say i think of all
there's like been over a hundred
subpoenas that have been issued through
the january 6 uh subcommittee when you
subpoena people's documents and records
you can ask broadly for tons and tons of
stuff they aren't being specific in what
they want and that to me shows that they
are kind of grasping at
straws like they are wanting you to turn
over stuff so they can figure out later
what you did wrong that's creepy yeah is
that the kind of thing where they can
create like fabricate a warrant after
the fact and make it look like they had
it back in the day no we we know this
guy this this epstein-linked judge
signed off on it and so a lot of people
are asking questions about this but a
lot of people are bringing up now that
they think this is a false flag right
before the midterms for an october
surprise or for this to be weaponized to
help democrats
look i gotta say i don't i
show me the evidence i mean i certainly
understand the possibilities but show me
the evidence considering what happened
with ray epps i'm more inclined to
believe there's malfeasance going on at
the highest level this is a guy who went
out on january on the not on january 5th
and 6th telling people to go in and
they're just like oh this poor man is a
victim that's what the new york times is
writing about that's what they're
claiming adam kinser is defending the
guy and i'm like something doesn't make
sense we know this guy he's on camera
saying it and they let him go
so with this
look the simple the simple answer
people are shocked and angered by the
fbi raiding the former president's house
and out of the 74 million trump voters
one guy went nuts yeah or one guy was
nuts and then went off right right
that's it i don't know unless you guys
think i'm wrong and the fed's planned
everything but i just don't i don't i
don't know no i think it's legit i think
this guy legitimately just like freaked
out or was already freaked out
i'm
i'm thinking about like
like obviously you don't attack people
that's not the way we live in a
civilized society we have our second
amendment because if we're attacked by
our own government or by outside
countries that we can defend ourselves
and like i think about like nazi germany
like
i used to be like why didn't they fight
back why didn't they like stop hitler
and stop the nazis and like
you kind of don't can't because it's
illegal to fight the law yeah it's also
people are cowards i mean the last two
years have really shown me a lot of
facets of human nature that i was just
maybe in denial about but people are
sheep and they are like they just kneel
at the face of power and
all common sense goes out the window and
i i mean i can there's a lot of things
in history that makes sense we're only a
couple months away from
a very very serious election
you've got people saying you know let
trump's second term begin january 3rd or
whatever 2023 or whenever they do the
the swearing-in yeah of these members of
congress in the senate and uh or members
of congress and so now is the most
crucial time just the other day this is
funny we had naomi wolfe and she said
it's gonna get crazy these next few
months right before the midterms and
we're like oh yeah baby if you thought
it was crazy before wait till you see
what's gonna happen next shut up the
next day some guy goes up to the fbi
field office with a nail gun
and a rifle and he tries breaking in
i mean this is crazy stuff yeah but but
i i don't know man the false flag
narrative stuff the reason i don't like
it as much as we've talked about gulf of
tonkin numerous times i understand the
possibilities i know all about operation
northwoods and this crazy stuff that
they've done in the past it's like you
you need evidence extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence i'd love
to believe we've exposed some nefarious
plot great well let's expose it but in
order to do so you can't start with the
premise that's extraordinary
you have to start with the what happened
a claim has been made it's been reported
in the press that a guy did these things
it's appeared on social media this guy
said these things now we need to start
from there and then see where we go not
decide where we want to be and then try
and build our way up to it but you know
by pointing out other things throughout
history all right
yeah i mean i i
am curious to see sort of how it plays
out but i imagine that they're going to
try to paint him
i there was another sort of recent
incident where you know it came out like
oh this this guy follows ben shapiro and
he was radicalized by ben shapiro like
yeah yeah the nerdy orthodox dude from
la that was definitely who radicalized
that shooter
um but i mean they're gonna they're
gonna ride this into the sunset just
like they have january 6th but i think
they blame radicalization on the
introduction of any information that
they don't agree with right so it's not
that
ben shapiro himself is like
waving some crazy symbols and acting
erratic it's that he opens the door to a
line of thought and a line of
questioning that ultimately they would
argue is always corrupt and always
violent which i don't think is
ultimately something is happening in
this country with the rise of parallel
economy
alternate payment processor system
censorship resistance resistant we use
them rumble
what you've got growing in florida with
not just the technology infrastructure
but with you know ron desantis
his his world view
what what florida's been doing in
general in terms of uh governing
something is is is amassing in this
country that's starting to stop
the insanity stop the cult now i'm not
saying
it's a guaranteed you know it's gonna
it's gonna you know this wokeness is
going to be crushed or anything like
that
but we're seeing
a steady path a light at the end of the
tunnel where we are going to be reaching
a good place
for something like this to happen
completely undermines the opportunity
for success so it does make you wonder
why would anyone on the right staring
down the barrel of a midterm election be
like i know here's what's going to help
no absolutely not this is the opposite
of doing anything good for anyone yeah i
mean he's probably just a nut job
honestly
yeah and then what do you do what do you
do when you have all these nut jobs what
are you supposed to do should they have
like been tracking his social media or
something no
no well and also who's to say they
weren't like right
and then let it happen we don't know
anything about this guy yet every time
there's a mass shooter
there's never the like oh i had no idea
he was sitting there everyone's like
yeah no he was a he was a nut job and we
were kind of waiting on this
it's never a secret it's never a
surprise yeah a lot of times their high
school classmates are like yeah that was
the guy that beat puppies
yeah and i think what happens now is
that
the
the powers that be that want him to be
representational of every maga supporter
out there are going to work really hard
to say like he is just like that guy
down the street from you who has a trump
2024 sign you know they're going to work
really hard to make this he is one of
them when in reality just like we know
the left has had i mean wasn't the guy
who opened fire at that country music
concert in las vegas didn't they i don't
know how we don't know anything about
that i don't know any about him because
he disappeared but there was a point
where people were saying like hey i
think he is a registered democrat and
then suddenly he disappeared i don't
know if that's true there's nothing i
can do to fact check it but
my point is just that ultimately we know
that there are people who whether it be
for mental reasons or whatever else pick
extremist behavior but that's not
actually number one
helpful to the political party that
they're going to link him to and
it's not actually representational to
most voters on either side i think guilt
by association isn't real
think about fast and furious no i will
not not the movies the operation by
obama where he gave guns to the cartels
i don't think about that either what
would they have been willing to do to
cover up something like that
yeah the question the question is
don't look at fast and the furious and
say wow look what they did
look at what they did and think what
could they be doing now that we don't
know about yeah so i
i i have to be like a little bit careful
because this is like
but there's i i know someone who was
involved in that
as a as a gun runner and uh
yeah i mean that was that was
there was a setup there was some messed
up stuff that happened on the part of
the feds and uh they did try to cover it
up in vegas or what uh he was in in the
southeast part of the or southwest
yeah yeah fast and furious yeah yeah
right and he was arrested as a gun
runner in that and i know him very well
and
it was he was set up and then they tried
to put him in prison for a very long
time and he spent a lot of money for his
freedom with for a very very very good
lawyer who was like i'm gonna bring this
to trial because he has nothing to lose
and y'all
might not want this all to be out there
yeah and his lawyer got him an amazing
deal and he got out like a year later
because the lawyer basically put him put
the feds on the spot and we're like he
was 17 and an orphan like
do you want to go into like how you
entrapped him and then how you like the
whole thing and
yeah yeah that was that was for me
someone who was like very back the blue
like i didn't see i i never really knew
that side of the fbi before to hear his
story someone who i trusted implicitly
and see how it all went down up close
was like
oh they bad
yeah
those are not good people
yep
and here we are
yeah well but i don't know
i i'm only bringing this up because i'm
i'm not trying to intimidate anything
about this particular instant uh
instance but there there probably are
tons of stories like i mentioned this
because of the vegas thing people have
questions nobody knows who this guy was
or what happened it all just vanishes
one day yeah and a lot of people are
like shouldn't we have like learned way
more information about this like with
every other incident
or maybe what was happening was there's
something going on behind the scenes
that went south yeah and they they're
not going to tell you you know the funny
thing is
i really don't want to get into the
issue of 9 11 because it's just people
can lose it but i always tell people
like do you believe the official story
you think the government just came out
and told you exactly how our security
was undermined i mean that's absurd
there's confidential and top-secret
information so of course the official
story is omitting information lacking
information and probably obvious getting
information so it's crazy to me when
for one there's obviously a lot of the
conspiracy theorists who believe
i think they take leaps of faith to
believe things they want to believe but
then also the people come out and say
like i will blindly believe whatever the
government says and then i'm like dude
even that would require you to say the
government was not honest about what
happened because if you like let's just
say it again
the united states government did not
come out on 911 and say uh here's a road
map to how our security was undermined
and please you know this we want can you
read that no they were like okay we
better let people know that happened
right there because that's how they got
us so they're not going to release all
the information
but you know that being said it's hard
to know when secrets are kept from the
american people and then we're supposed
to make decisions on who we vote for
without complete information and then
you have the media organizations that
inten intentionally obfuscate and
manipulate
dark days indeed i'll put it that way it
seems like um there's a defense of the
liberal economic order right now by
american military and sub-military like
fbi and cia that they don't want it to
get broken up they want to make sure
that we the united states we have like a
police not a police state but like
control of the earth like we have
military bases all over so there's no
world war iii breaks out
i understand that they don't want world
war three to break out but like i don't
think that the the the real threat is
internal it doesn't seem like that i
think most people want stability in the
united states like the ccp may be a
bigger threat probably i don't know man
i i don't know if it matters what we
think or feel about who the bigger
threat is i think it's obvious china is
a serious threat i mean honestly russia
is a threat they just i think they over
hype russia when china has a much bigger
threat but the fact is we've got two
distinct cultures in this country and
they're and
they're headed for some you know for
chaos yeah i was going to say
maybe a lot of people want stability but
what they view as stable is not the same
thing there's such a division in how
people uh ascribe their values and what
they would describe as their ideal
stable life right there are people who
are
incompatible in a lot of ways in this
country obviously i don't think that's a
call for like extremist violence or
anything like that but like
you have to recognize that stability is
almost impossible when you have people
who need your life to be different and
you see that as well yeah just like real
real quick so i do want to bring up this
next story just as an aside which we'll
get into later on maybe for the members
only a video is going viral from the
boston children's hospital talking about
giving hysterectomies
to children oh it's freakish to children
so so we'll get into all that but i want
you brought back the blue so i have this
tweet here from brianna joy gray oh boy
she said marjorie taylor green is right
about the fbi bad faith or not in
today's radar i argue the left should
take advantage of the right's new
acknowledgement of systemic bias and
push to abolish the fbi an institution
that is always protected has always
protected elite power not the people
my response to this was fire emojis i
know i completely agree i i i was
thinking i was like i'm actually a p
that appeals to me
um
but i mean i think that uh
sort of
i disagree a little bit about the fact
that both sides want stability i i don't
think that the other side wants
stability i think they want to remake
the world but this is not that this is
this is an
appreciation and understanding that the
fbi at least
maybe maybe beyond a joy gray in the
left perspective on this is we need to
tear down the system to rebuild a new
one don't no don't care if we have if we
if we look at the fbi and we're like hey
there's corruption going on there we
should defund that and and dismantle it
and they say yeah we also want to i'd
like well if we agree on that we're fine
moving forward we'll figure out
afterwards well then what here's the
problem
then what comes next yeah right like a
new organization that's even less
accountable yeah that we don't even know
i don't know and the tracks are you
cannot
you you can't say we should not do away
with corrupt institutions because of
fear of more corrupt institutions it's
like we're actually taking action yeah
but you can't like take a wheel off the
car mid mid drive yeah you have to is
that what the fbi is it's one of the
ones are they that important for the
united states have they been
investigating antifa have they been have
have they been holding people
accountable have they been going after
hunter biden and i mean no well we may
see something with hunter biden but it's
been a really long time and only because
of public scrutiny right so i'm not
convinced
that first i'll say i don't think the
entirety of the fbi is corrupt i think
there's different people in different
field offices i've actually talked with
people
who uh you know there's like lower level
people who there's credits they have
similar politics to you the culture war
is in every facet of the government as
well but
i just don't know if the fbi does
enough well no to warrant any of this i
mean it's a secret of operation that's
part of the problem
that's not what i'm saying i'm not
saying no one knows i'm saying we have
repeatedly asked questions for years why
have they not done this that or
otherwise yet they have time to send a
dozen agents to a garage over a pole
rope
that is shockingly
shockingly insane
the time of the jesse smallett no i'm
talking about the
the bubble watson was that his name i
don't know the nascar nascar driver said
there was a noose in his garage and so
they sent a dozen agents what did they
find it was a garage pole rope it was
the door pull rope
it's wallace
it's insane
and then they go and and merrick garland
signs off on raiding the former
president's home and we're sitting here
being like let's contemplate whether
they're an organization worth funding no
no no no there's no question the left
has long talked about
all of the malfeasance they talk about
martin luther king and malcolm x's
really big examples and i'm like sure
fine whatever yeah
defund them dismantle them or maybe
maybe we can start by reducing through a
moderate defunding and reduction of the
fbi force yeah i mean i think the fbi
there's two problems one of them is
their it's the problem of every
government institution it's just
bureaucratic
bloat and
stupid people get
promoted and
your expertise and your it's not a
meritocracy is basically what i'm saying
i think that's a number one problem but
i think that
in the last five years one of the things
that has become extremely apparent
is that the people who are in charge
like the grown-ups in charge i always
thought that there was grown-ups in
charge and then like
comey
and he started talking and you're like
oh my god you had a lot of power and you
are a total nut job uh but it's all of
these people who were in the top rungs
of power who are not jobs
george conway is another one peter
fricken not
adam kinzinger i don't know him
personally but i've been seeing his
tweets and i think he's isolated there
seems to be like um a bubble that some
of these people are existing in right
now that they think it's really what
life is about is about red and blue
democrat republican thing but that's
like an infinitesimally small part of
reality yeah this human thing is not
that big a part of reality we need to
really kind of get outside of our own
butthole if you know what i'm talking
about and look out
look outside but that's what i said
bubble that's what i said butthole yeah
uh we need to we need to de-investigate
ourselves for a moment and look around
at the universe because things are
flying around at 100 million miles per
hour and can slam into earth at any
moment and we gotta be prepared for that
kind of thing and and that
is an important mentality for people to
realize like you can find purpose
outside of all of this
most of these democrats this is their
life their religion their purpose they
have nothing else maybe if they
got interested in the stars they might
be like yo i don't care about this i
want to look in a telescope instead
their whole world i'll put it this way
politics has become pop culture yeah
that's that's the danger
and public health has become part of
their identity too i mean covet would
gave them a religion like most of them
i'm so happy that for you you finally
have found faith and it's you know in
the form of virus medication yep
although the cdc relaxed guidelines i
don't know if that's come up yet we
talked about before the show
officially uh i was according to npr
they reported on that today maybe going
to that later a little bit i i just
can't help thinking with the fbi there's
so much clear and evident mouse you can
look at peter strzok i just cherish the
way he smirked it was insane he looked
ideologically these people and blasey
ford did the same thing they do this
thing where they look in the camera and
they look down and go what the
what is that are you are you are you
imagining you're the wicked witch of the
west or something
the problem is the camera's above like
what we got on the show so it's looking
down at them so you see like their eyes
looking up like
a problem we we don't look to the camera
turn our heads down look up and then go
for yourself too creepy okay we don't do
that
yeah well we're not hiding stuff i mean
why are they doing not more than a
normal person would hide some you know
menial personal or private things on tv
but like i think these people have to
have secret that's their job is like
secrecy half these people in the
government the cia secrecy organization
oh it's all secrets yeah so that's the
remarkable thing it's like anytime
anyone from the government comes out and
says words like why would you believe
them they have a whole system of keeping
information a secret from you they're
not going to tell you yeah i mean the
the the people who go to the white house
press conference
i'm just
do you really think
any white house press secretary at any
point ever is going to tell you the
truth i'm sorry if you believe that i
got a bridge to sell you you think the
first one did no first one no i mean the
thing is
the government trades in strategically
releasing information so why would that
be true in foreign policy and not true
in our
domestic media like why would we be like
oh yes american people i'm taking myself
i'm going to be on uh national tv and
i'm going to tell you the truth but
don't tell anyone else because that will
reveal our big plan like we
can't
reasonably expect our government to be
honest with us and
also be openly telling everyone all of
our adversaries like what's truly going
on with us like that seems like a
terrible plan yeah i mean i i i judge
all of the press secretaries by their
ability to lie yes and that's the job
and suspect
and some of them are good and some of
them are not good and have you had a
favorite
oh gosh
so sarah huckabee sanders was fantastic
nothing
the key is and i think it's the bunch of
kids
nothing
here's the story right here ah yes
you're wrong yeah that was fantastic
but uh jen sackey wasn't bad she's not
like she wasn't yet yeah people you
might not like her but her ability to
spin and spin quickly and create sound
bites she got to do it this this current
lady terrible oh man
she's terrible because they did a
checklist they're like well she checks
the lbgtq and she checks the woman and
she checks but they didn't actually like
have a check mark for charisma merit
for talent or anything yeah she's just
completely enacted i feel bad i know i
mean she's not over her head and she was
she was chosen because if she hit all
those little boxes and she has been from
what i know about her career i mean
she's been fairly insulated she's been
with the democratic movement for so long
she i think people who are farther on
the outside of the the shell have to
learn how to spar a little bit more and
i think to her credit that's where jen
saki's background came from whereas with
uh cringe on pierre like no she has she
has been with movement she knows the
sound bites and when challenged she
really struggles yeah no absolutely i
mean i think that was that's actually a
skill of like pete bootaj because he
like was in middle america and had to
actually talk to people with whom he
disagreed it makes me sharper i mean
i went to rutgers university with like
every lib on on planet earth except
james o'keefe you know you know what
what really works though is believing
what you're saying yes that helps
because knowing what you're saying
because you don't need a book i mean
it's nice to have notes but you don't
need to look at them if you know if you
just glance down and then talk about
what you know you know i mean i'm here
with the formula stuff she genuinely had
no answer she didn't know that there was
a formula crisis she didn't know the
plan like she did not
there was no
there was nothing not to believe she
just didn't know it for the record
andrew johnson was the first president
to grant a formal interview to a
reporter wow that was 1869.
yeah so before that i guess they didn't
even they didn't even talk to the media
for the first 60 70 years it's kind of
crazy if you think about it i mean like
you have no idea what they're doing
i mean when was the last time biden
spoke to anyone he he rarely talks about
he yells come on man quite a bit you
know with a helicopter
and i would argue to the first 50 60
years media was really different than
what it is yeah radio and tv have
changed a lot yeah i mean you have to
get a journalist to a president to then
put a paper out that would then like by
the time it reached anyone be like three
weeks old and i mean radio and tv is the
reason why hitler was able to mask the
population so fast and it's super
dangerous tech i understand why there's
censorship and why the the cia is
involved with you know the prism thing
and they want to oversee and make sure
but like
we should talk more about the power of
tv and video i think maybe not today but
i think in life tv was more powerful
than social media with tv you had five
channels starting with three channels
then five so all of the messaging was
distilled through the trusted names and
news or whatever then the internet
happened and you can reach people faster
but
now you've got too many channels yeah
and they're all just all these poles
busted on the damn and trying to plug
them like ah we have conventional
fingers we don't know how to plug all
these at once i think make an algorithm
like the tick tock algorithm people can
get you know the more they use it the
more it knows them and so it feeds them
to like edgar allan poe tick tock like
that person is not getting the same
content that like you would get or you
would get that's true for all the
platforms true yeah yeah but tick tock
is especially talented at it there was
the the wall street journal story about
like young teenagers 13 14 years old and
they lingered on one pornographic video
and then they were just inundated with
more and more pornographic content yeah
that sounds like they're not better at
it no they're very good at it because
they got the kids hooked on the app
and it was because they just if you
lingered 0.3 seconds it's longer every
second on tick tock it
is more valuable to them partially
because the media is so short which
keeps you scrolling faster whereas like
youtube you may have to watch you know
you watch one video it might feed you
another you watch 10 videos it'll feed
you right but i mean aren't these videos
are over an hour like you really have to
invest some time but you can have like
total add on tick tock on youtube i've
noticed if i go to a video and i
and i watch it for like half of half the
length of the video or more that it
starts to hit me with more videos that
so like if i go to one i'm like no no no
i don't want no no i don't want this in
my life you just x out really fast so
then the algorithm knows you don't want
it
i try to trick the instagram algorithm
because it started um i had a like
family friend who like she had like this
tragic thing with a dying kid or
whatever and then the instagram
algorithm decided i only wanted to see
stories about dying children yeah it
does that to me too and i was like i'm
going to click on every single thing
about meghan markle let's like let's
trick the algorithm that's worse
no i mean it's better than dying
children and i hate meghan markle so i'm
all in i'm saturated with cats and it
creates a
compounding effect where i watch more
cat videos because they're giving me
more to look at and then i get even more
and now it's all cats when i go through
my stories i decided i was like a young
mormon bride because i was really
interested in national parks so you
click on a lot of like photography in
zion national park and then it was like
but you know who takes pictures in zion
national parks
mormons and then it fed me a lot of
mormon church stuff and i really was
like i don't i don't know what's
happening so i gave my brother my phone
and he uh
looks for other things and he mormonized
it oh yeah yeah it still occasionally is
like but are you sure i mean and are you
sure
are you questioning i really want to see
zion national park and i don't know if
i'm willing to commit to them did you
linger on the mormon videos and then
they were like she's definitely i think
it was like
here are photographers active in this
area and then because utah is
an lds you know stronghold it's like
well here are people who are hiring
photographers and then it was like well
here are the mommy bloggers and i was
like oh look at those kids and then it
kept going and eventually i was like
this is creepy i don't like it at all i
know i love it i that's that's my jam
it's better than the dead kids that's
for sure the algorithm you love or well
no the out yet algorithm because i get
that algorithm too i get all the like
moms of well it's funny because i get
all of the like big family people on
instagram because i follow a couple of
them and then it sort of compounds and
then they start getting crazier crazier
and crazier and it is hard not to be
like what are you doing it's like your
own customized version of reality tv
yeah like it's like i think i know what
plot lines you're going to be into and i
will serve you kind of the danger of
hate watching too because sometimes i'll
watch stuff because i find it so like
revolting i gotta know i know so this is
the libs of tick tock she says like i'm
i'm friendly with her she said like i
didn't even like i just started watching
them and then
tick tock just feeds me more and more i
don't go looking for them and now people
send them to her because she's had such
a big account but she like she built
this entire platform on just posting
what the algorithm showed her which was
craziness interesting i think
i get a lot of marvel stuff nice yeah i
get like like
skateboarding rollerblading scooting
biking all of that i guess that's like
the only thing i really watch
and a whole bunch of marvel's
the new the new movies that are coming
out and then there's like a lot of music
stuff but it's usually just like a guy
they said i don't i don't scoot but they
sent me a video of a guy doing a triple
flare on a scooter and i just couldn't
stop watching it it was like cool even
though that was a verb scoot scooter
yeah a triple flare for like it was like
the you know that is no it's like
so a flare is like a backflip 180 so
triple is like three back flips into 180
it's just i'm just sitting there on the
toilet and i'm like
that is crazy it's like just keep
watching again watch again
and i follow like the barracks and stuff
like that when i started doing pop
culture crisis i would occasionally look
up like people who were involved in the
stories on my phone and so then for a
while it was sending me lots of like
e-news and then it would send you like
people who like do their own content
about following various celebrities and
i have never been so informed in my life
you know the worst thing about instagram
now is
they give you like when you're scrolling
through your feed you get accounts you
don't follow yes i am so annoyed i just
like every time i see it i'm like get
rid of it get rid of it it's like i'm
watching videos of a dude doing a 360
flip crook down a rail and i'm like whoa
i'm watching a video of a guy doing like
a backside flip going 30 miles an hour
and i'm like whoa and then it shows me a
woman jump roping and i'm like
i don't i don't care about this i don't
remove why did you put that in my feed
yeah but i will say this for instagram
the personal shopper is on oh crazy oh
so good on point i actually i call it my
personal shopper it's not even
advertising i buy everything i do too
they once advertised me so my older son
had food allergies when he was younger
i once got and targeted ad
for
uh yarmulkes because we're orthodox
jewish
kid yarmulkes for kids who are not
really talking yet
with allergy information listed on the
yamaha great i was like
so many data points there that were
orthodox jews with a young son with food
allergies who was too young to verbalize
them yet it lined it up and it was like
we know what y'all thought and i the
singularity i won't buy anything off the
instagram like it serves me stuff i like
but i just like sometimes i feel like i
can't help it like i don't really want
to give i want to feed it because it's a
singularity the singularity has occurred
like the ai is in control that excites
me that i mean the instagram one of the
instagram or a puppet because my mind is
strong enough i think that i'm able to
tend information without believing it or
disbelieving it enough that i could
exist within the algorithm and function
wrong piece excuse me
excuse me wrong i mean you see here's
what's happening when you get fed
information on social media it is
shaping your world view and you don't
have control over that i have noticed
man a lot of people i follow on twitter
are people that have been on the show
and it's a lot of politics i do not like
it man and i like those people i want to
i want to know what they're up to in
life but i can't stand reading about the
left and the right and the color red
follow my instance down yeah i'm a
completely different person on instagram
yeah i am delightful on instagram and
i'm awful on twitter
interesting yeah but twitter is um
for most people it's not algorithmic
it's reverse chronological you can
choose to do the algorithmic or
otherwise so for me i follow news i mean
twitter is the news platform there's
like not much else on their celebrities
don't really get traction they're like
they're there they've big following but
like i never see those tweets yeah
they're on it they go on instagram for
that stuff but on instagram
they're feeding you stuff in your feed
and shaping your world view
just just outright facebook as well
facebook is where it's substantially
worse so i don't really use facebook so
i don't know but instagram nothing is
shaping my worldview because it's just
pictures of like homeschool classrooms
which is great and i love them and i've
taken a lot of information but you're
you know
i think for younger people
they're being inundated with very
specific things but is it like do people
get their news from instagram yeah i
think they do and i think for especially
some young people they'll follow like uh
meme accounts on instagram that'll be
not political memes like silly like uh
what it's like when you're in 20 right
and like
then those accounts start to promote you
know maybe they really believe them but
maybe you know just part of the culture
they know certain things will get more
likes and so they start incorporating
certain content that's more pro certain
issues especially i saw the slot after
um
ruby wade was um overturned and i had
people jump on that bandwagon like there
was no more people who are not
particularly political and maybe this is
an important issue them and they just
don't vocalize it i grant that some
people are like that um but
a lot of accounts picked up on the fact
that it was correct to you know
lifestyle
kind of content i think that that would
have happened even without social media
though i think that your social media
reinforces it because people who don't
seek out political information are
served it anyways through this backdoor
channel of like look at these cute jeans
i got also my row pin also there was
interesting sort of
stuff that was leaked from marketing
firms after row
i mean dobbs
that a lot of brands were told like
don't touch it that they they went all
in on black lives matter and so i know
people who are like pretty big
influencers on instagram and they got
questions like why didn't you post a
black box like where was your black box
during black lives matter and it i feel
like the the corporate pressure was not
the same with dobbs i think because
dobbs is more complicated and they knew
it from the beginning whereas with the
black box thing it was like you must
submit i mean i remember the culture
that surrounded in some ways the leak of
the road decision that came out like
ahead of time i think was trying to
build the same tension that we had
during the summer of rioting uh after
george floyd's death yeah you know
yeah it sets the circumstances very
differently sorry i want to jump to this
next story we got this from timcast.com
twitter announced his plan to tackle
misleading narratives ahead of midterms
vows to throttle tweets deemed incorrect
exciting like they did not do with all
the democrats who were screaming that
the election was stolen in 2016. they're
now basically telling us
they are going to decide what is true
the last election they did this what did
they do they suppressed the hunter biden
laptop information they suppressed
anything that was that was basically bad
for democrats and now they intend to do
it again
so i i don't know if there's any point
in reading and what they claim is going
to be done they're civilians this seems
like a really good news site i think you
maybe should read it no no but the point
is like why who cares about what twitter
has to say about why they're going to be
censoring and controlling the flow of
information i'd like to hear a little
bit about it what's the official
statement here at least the civic
integrity policy covers the most common
types of harmful misleading information
about elections and civic events such as
claims about how to participate in civic
process like how to vote misleading
content intended to intimidate or
dissuade people from participating in
the election and misleading claims
intended to undermine public confidence
in an election including false
information about the outcome of the
election twitter said in the
announcement
harmful the thing about all that is
you're allowed to do all that stuff
that's free speech as long as you're not
inciting violence sort of not not
entirely i mean you're allowed to tell
people not to vote yes but you're i
don't think you're allowed to defraud
people by like telling them the wrong
voting day
oh right things like that okay so i
follow a great account um his name is
political math it's polymath on twitter
yeah i love him and so he tweeted he
retweeted the cdc's guidance about
um the kids vaccine between six months
and five years old saying like
absolutely get you know these young
children vaccinated and polymath
retweeted it and said fire these people
this is unspeakable stupidity on the
part of the cdc that agency should be
burned to the ground which is opinion
yes first of all it's opinion and second
of all well it's a call to violence
that's their interpretation no they call
it misleading oh okay they don't call it
a troll to violence but
if you look at the numbers of people who
have had their young children vaccinated
for kobe between six months and five
years of age i wrote about this for
deseret like two weeks ago the numbers
are like three percent right now so when
i see a misleading tag on polymath's
opinion about the cdc's statement
it makes me be like oh there is
something up there like it backfires
right yeah because i see that and i
think like why are they gatekeeping like
but i think a lot of this is just failed
it's it's
what's the right word what's what's the
politically correct word of saying your
brain doesn't work the people at twitter
are really dumb and there are people at
twitter that are really evil and then
you have the government trying to get
twitter to censor people which we've
heard over and over and over again now
so what happens is they're like hey
let's implement a policy what happens
there was there have been several
instances where people's tweets have
been flagged and the fact check is
totally unrelated and it's like this
really weird thing like huh there have
been several instances where guidance
has changed and they've been like hey
we're revive the cdc is like we're
providing our guidance and then twitter
flags it is fake news here's what the
cdc says and then links to like an
article from the year before
there was a famous incident on facebook
where the c i think it was the cdc's own
website was labeled fake news
because these machines don't work yeah
they don't know context they don't have
up-to-date information
and so if someone's like i got breaking
news the cdc says x they'll delete you
and say that was fake news and you're
banned because our official fact
checkers have not yet published the
information yeah so when they talk about
getting involved in the election at what
point
i you know you know you know i don't
want to say it i was going to say at
what point do we as a society do
something about the interference and
manipulation of our elections the
problem is there's no there's no
mechanism for for solving this and
there's no uh there's no that that's it
there's no political process for solving
it
it's just there twitter is this corrupt
broken evil machine and i don't care if
the intention put into it was good what
came out was evil
and there and what do you do anti-trust
the people who run this this platform
are all out of their minds
elon doesn't even want it anymore and he
said he hopes that he doesn't have to
buy it
there's no there's no saving these
broken social media platforms it's like
you build a machine that runs wild and
starts destroying you and you don't know
what what to do to stop it well you got
to free the schematics so that people
someone will figure out how to stop it
that's why i advocate for freeing the
software code you can at least make it
better and more interoperable i think
that people aren't going to be able to
take twitter's code and then change
twitter they're going to be able to
replicate it maybe exactly more
problematic versions of the same goal or
better and then the people on twitter
will be like oh we could do that let's
change our better does not mean better
for society i know better could mean
generates more revenue which means worse
because now it's more algorithmic
manipulation
making people click and get
you know depends on who you ask better
could mean more manipulation of the
masses to get them to vote for who i
want them to vote for
but i think better uh you know i kind of
think uh
what are you allotropically i think
that's not the right word but i think
like you know the betterment of the
whole of uh
the community like
i no one i don't want less constriction
on who's controlling it but i guess i
don't know i'm not in the military the
military commander would tell you that's
the you want to do the opposite with it
probably that you want to control it
military that's the only reason you're
not in the military yeah i don't want to
control people but i mean that's the
military's job
but i think with the twit like i think
it's nice to believe that people would
want to rally around common good and the
betterment of other people that's
honorable and that's moral in a lot of
ways but
why would twitter
and i don't know what time about freeing
the code for sure but like
why would freeing the code motivate
people who are already important
well ask a question okay so
twitter has a history of wanting to
manipulate people and control the
worldview why would freeing the code
suddenly change
their mind why would they suddenly if
someone else made something that was
similar but more moral why would they be
like that's a good idea we should do
that too they could have done that
already but they chose not to the issue
is
twitter is not driven by morality moral
platforms exist and they don't have
traction what works is addiction
machines instagram knows this facebook
knows this twitter knows youtube knows
this tic-tac knows this they know that
they can give you a dopamine hit
by making you feel good and they they
they have this built into their machines
so
there are tech companies
that
offer a service to generate addiction
they'll say are you building an app come
to us and we will build an addiction
routine into your app for you to make
your machines and stuff they actually
figure out when you pull it down how
long do you want how addictive you know
how long do you want to wait until it
refreshes how many times you need to win
how many dings are you going to get
right but what would happen is
if if they freed the code that
guy number two would build set up his
own identical addiction machine
identical to twitter and equally as
addictive but on his thing he gets to
make his own terms of service he'll say
on mine you can talk about the cdc say
whatever you want all these people on
twitter will will try this one
and then they'll still be no they won't
why would they move i mean they're
allowed to talk about but no one's here
but it's not happening okay they haven't
freed the code yet that's what i'm
saying no this is my let me at least
state my claim here so you can argue you
you set your claim all the time and the
action and hannah claire asked me the
question i want to answer it so it
then you
you make it so you can still see the
people on twitter from the new site so
you're not actually
leaving you're just expanding the
process and you're creating um a
marketplace of the terms of service
essentially instead of a marketplace of
who owns the code so how does that not
already exist
with with with truth social with parlor
with getter with gab they're not in our
minds they don't interoperate with each
other yet and and why would they
well bigger network that that has
nothing to do with more diverse
networking the the issue is
you cannot make a morally better system
a system that improves like twitter or
facebook is more addictive and
manipulative and power hungry so there's
there's no solution maybe anti-trust but
twitter is not a monopoly technically so
they're other players
for sure exactly and so there's
literally there is no mechanism we have
today other than like all of the people
of this country agree it's bad so we we
we pass a law saying ban twitter so
here's my question for you prohibition
so
opening the co freeing the code so would
this basically provide a window because
here's what i'm curious about as a in as
a twitter user what happened with alex
berenson
like can someone explain that yeah he
wanted to be on twitter
no i mean like what ha he was banned and
now he's back he filed a lawsuit because
he wanted to be back on twitter he
didn't want to go on any other platform
he wanted to be on twitter so it was the
lawsuit that got him back on he had a
lawyer on last week he settled with
twitter
they settled and he got his account back
interesting so would freeing the code
basically do what alex did and and open
the door
okay oh yeah well you could so alex if
he got banned off twitter he could go on
the new version and still see all the
people on twitter from his new version
and he wouldn't be banned off the new
version why would their database be be
granted to you why would you get access
to their database because you have the
api you'd have access yeah yeah that
would be i mean that would be the law
that would be what you would have i'll
tell you this right now it's the reason
why i don't like talking about this is
that it literally makes no sense i don't
think so because the other option is
breaking up the company like an
anti-trust and that doesn't work because
they still have the code they can start
a new one what i want to know is
like who is the person who decided
to ban alex berenson like what was the
what was the decision-making process
there it is likely the government
intervened we don't know for sure so
that's what i want to know though we
don't know
and we'd love it if alex berenson could
like you know tell everybody and that's
why people are really mad at him because
the story goes and you know i don't want
to put words in his mouth or the mouth
of his followers but what people are
saying on twitter in response to him is
that he promised when he got to
discovery he would expose what was going
on instead he settled with twitter got
his account back and then said sorry oh
that's yucky so people are like you know
he he said in the future there will be
more to to to talk about in terms of
government involvement and censorship
and things like that we heard from naomi
wolfe she said that the cdc was going
after specifically she was kicked off
right she's not yeah oh no and so
something oh your bracelet daughter's
bracelet so she was saying that it's
we see this before uh judicial watch
uncovered documents i believe it was
judicial watch that democrats were going
to
these big tech companies saying ban
these people
so so it's it's very at this point i
would say we're at probable cause or
beyond we have actual instances of
evidence where the government is using
third parties to violate people's first
amendment rights but they're doing it
circuitously so this was the lawsuit
that was just filed by a whole bunch of
the healthcare people
or
do you i i don't know a lot about it but
it was the um i think it was
jay out in
san
stanford stanford dr j and i can't say
his last name
b
this is all new i'm so glad when people
don't know things that i don't know i'm
so spaced out right now no so there
there's a lawsuit that was just filed
and it's funny i actually just did a
radio hit about it and the host did the
worst thing in the world he's like tell
me about this i'm like i will not
talk about it no thank you you have to
you have to do that and so i kind of
like i muddled through it as best i
could but there was a lawsuit filed by a
whole bunch of health care people
about the fact that the
cdc and the government worked in
conjunction with the social media
companies wow
to silence them which is a violation of
the first amendment yeah the government
does not have the right to go to
companies and say ban these people don't
let them speak
yeah now the issue is as always it's
cultural
cultural enforcement is more powerful
than law enforcement and cultural drives
are more powerful than any platform
could be you can spin up as many
platforms as you want from truth social
to gab to parlor to getter etc etc and
people don't use them they don't unify
on them and why why why didn't alex
berenson just go on truth social and
talk to those people why didn't he just
go on gab and talk to those people he
wanted to be on twitter so he sued to be
on twitter he accepted being on twitter
and then he didn't give the people what
they asked for because being on twitter
was more important to him because
people are on twitter yeah it's the
people it's not the platform can i
correct myself now that i've googled it
because i i'm i'm a little bit of a jerk
um the person who filed the lawsuit is
one of my friends and i didn't know that
oh cool oh my surprise i'm really sorry
justin hart
uh he's he's a data guy he's a marketing
digital strategist
um he filed a federal lawsuit against
facebook and twitter and joe biden and
the surgeon general for violating his
first amendment rights to free speech
he claims that the federal government
colluded with social media companies to
monitor flags to spend and even delete
social media posts that they'd
they claimed contained uh misinformation
he's being represented by liberty
justice center um i'm sorry justin i
didn't know that you were doing that i
will i will say there have been many
circumstances where big tech has been
sued and i am flabbergasted by the weak
arguments made in such strong cases
so uh there's just been a handful that i
don't want to call anybody out
specifically to impugn their honor but
there have been very very strong cases
where you're like wow look at the
details of this case clearly the
government said ban this person and then
when they file a lawsuit they don't
mention anything about like they don't
go they don't go after the government
they don't include them as part of the
lawsuit they don't even bring up the
strong elements of the case as arguments
they just say something like our
contract was breached and i'm like
what am i missing here because i've
talked to dozens of lawyers about
various issues and you know to put it
simply i'm not a lawyer i can't speak
for why these lawyers have made weak
cases that ended up losing or settling
or just not accomplishing what they want
to accomplish but then when you talk
when you when you listen to the lawyers
on their shows and you will you listen
to high profile people coming out and
explaining what went down
they make it sound like they had a much
better case and they presented and i
don't understand why they didn't go for
it i just don't know
or maybe they just didn't know i don't
know
inner workings of legal that you'll
never know i don't understand why more
news outlets haven't filed lawsuits
against newsguard for instance
they they like breitbart has written
articles being like how dare you news
guard it's like why don't you sue them
why don't you sue them yes
exactly you i know
uh-huh i'm asking you and we said this
last week
so like i don't watch every video no no
i'm not saying i'm not saying you do i'm
saying yes exactly because
we probably are okay i've been in a
dispute with them already they violated
their own standards they violated their
own correction policy they've accused us
of being irresponsible while holding
themselves to a lower standard stating
that we get an 82 out of 100 i i say
it's a statement of fact that they've
rated us on the basis that they are
giving a factual analysis but they are
not they don't follow their own
standards or policies and the reason i
take this so seriously people need to
understand this newsguard is used by
advertising agencies and big tech to
reduce visibility of your content so if
you sit so we're 82 out of 100 i mean
we're one of the one of the best but
they arbitrarily gave our website a ding
even though our standards are greater
than theirs right new you usa today
fabricated 23 stories and they say
that's fine
there's
i i want to be careful here because
there's some behind-the-scenes stuff
related to serious malfeasance but i
have already issued a demand to them and
it is very very likely we will be filing
a suit and i will probably seek
crowdfunding to help other organizations
that have been defamed by them falsely
and smeared in violation of their own
standards and there's a few a few things
people need to know about the elements
of defamation
actual malice did they know what they
published was false
when it comes to opinion statements this
is probably going to be their big
defense that
when we call you irresponsible it's an
opinion we'll get to that they've also
issued several false statements and
refused to correct them for instance on
the the label for our website they have
they claimed they mischaracterized a
post that's false they injected words
into it that's very different from this
characterization it's a false statement
of their actions defaming us they
accused our content of being fiction and
they did not as per their own policy
which is their standard admitted that
they said we were wrong to say tim cass
content is fictional
they did that instead just scrubbed it
from the article in violation of their
own policies so i'm i'm particularly
pissed off about this but um i'll put it
this way i've talked about uh wikipedia
standards how they put their own byline
in it i have no standing to go after
wikipedia you give me standing on any of
these platforms and the first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to go to the
full extent possible legally and so
there's been a long ongoing conversation
with newsguard for instance they first
tried to claim we were fake news because
we accurately reported the contents of
the hunter biden laptop they tried
getting us to editorialize our content
and i said here's two news guard
certified sources confirming the laptop
emails
are real and verified and their response
was
you know what this is a little bit murky
so we're gonna we're gonna ignore this
issue for now no you don't get to send
me an email demanding we editorialize
our content and then and then you omit
from your own article that you had an
error in your own assessments so i wait
when they published it with six errors
in right off the bat i emailed
immediately and demanded retractions
corrections and they have refused every
step of the way to correct newsguard
fabricated a quote from me that pissed
me off
you know when it when it was accusing uh
tales of the inverted world of being
fiction i said that is a false statement
and they changed it but never explained
as per their own policy what they did
wrong they called it a
mischaracterization i challenge that
that is a false statement of fact on
their own part i don't know how that'll
work in court but i'm really really
pissed off about this
their their rating system is arbitrary
they have dinged us simply because we
are an independent media organization
usa today fabricated 23 stories and they
give them a perfect score media matters
gets like an 80 out of 100 and they and
they're a conspiracy crackpot website so
anyway i'm i'm frustrated because i'm
pissed off at these institutions but i
believe we have serious standing and
reason to prove
that they have com there's actual malice
in the in the insertion of words into a
quote
knowing i did not say these things and
knowing i never implied them i'll give
you i'll give you exactly what it is
because they're trying to argue
when we put words in your quote we're
implying something we know you didn't
say it
i told them if you require a website to
fact check every single quote from every
every politician that is near impossible
but if that's what you require from this
we will we will do facts on all quotes
moving forward they inserted the words
that are false changing what i was
saying what i was saying was you have
you have demanded of us an impossible
standard oh my god by adding those words
they knew they were manipulating my
quote that is mouse and i want to see
what they wrote when they were talking
to their editors and lawyers as to why
they decided to change the context of
what i said
they did not admit it as per their own
correction policy they did that so i
think they outright defamed libeled me
and won't and so you have actual malice
and then reckless disregard for the
truth in that they don't abide by their
own standards so
in their fact-checking process they
three times incorrectly labeled my job
at three different organizations called
our content fake fiction and fantasy i'm
pissed off about that and they labeled
cast castle mundane which is an opinion
statement as per their own standard must
be labeled if they're not going to abide
by their own standards i am going to sue
the ever living out of them and you know
what if in the end the suit is dismissed
i long for the day newsguard files in
their federal response why they are
allowed to have zero standards for their
own for their own journalists why
they're allowed to fabricate quotes why
they're allowed to smear and defame a
plethora of independent media
organizations and why they give perfect
scores to outlets like cnn and new york
times who publish fake crap all the time
anyway i'm pissed off about it you can
tell a little bit i mean i think a lot
of it your question your initial
question how you got started in all this
was why isn't anyone suing and i think
it's two things think that people don't
care enough you're very obviously not
one of those people but i think the
other problem
is that
and i think we saw it a lot with kovid
people
are
much more content to go along because
they don't want to start things and so
even though they see things that are
objectively ridiculous like putting a
cloth mask on a two-year-old baby
people are afraid to speak up because
everyone is a coward and so i think that
there is a lot of that we had tucker max
on and he said power likes to be
hidden
you know i was asking them because we
bring us up quite a bit like where are
all the powerful people to just come out
make powerful statements buy commercials
put up billboards and challenge the
things we know they're privately
complaining about where are all the
hollywood celebrities that privately
complain about this stuff but then don't
stand up there's a really great comic
where it shows a guy burning a woman at
the stake and he says i want to let you
know i completely agree with everything
you said
that's that's that's modern mainstream
society unfortunately
so
i
i don't know man
i imagine sooner or later someone's
gonna get pissed off enough with me and
they're gonna try and do something we've
already been swatted nine times a little
nervous about that actually speaking of
which well we have we have armed
security and things like that i would
say one of the other things i think
happens is that it's expensive to to
make your legal battles a priority and i
think there are other independent media
companies who are probably being treated
i mean this is particularly uh
horrendous treatment of our organization
and of course i
i hesitate to comment on it because i've
been with tim cass since the newsroom
began i've been here for like a year so
this is a lot of my work that's being
scrutinized and
i am very glad that you're willing to do
something about it because i think we do
hold ourselves and all of our
journalists to an extremely high
standard that being said i do know there
are small organizations that would love
to go to court but have to make the
decision
can we
afford to do this because it can be
protracted especially when you fight
larger companies they can drag it out i
mean anyone who sued facebook for
anything knows this
yeah i think though
i imagine there's a community of people
who are willing to
stand up and be involved james o'keefe
from project veritas they've they've
crowdfunded
the fun the the the finance is required
to file a lawsuit and they're going up
against the new york times and
regardless this is what people need to
understand too
winning doesn't mean having a judge bang
a gavel and say for the plaintiff
winning means getting these
organizations to admit they're liars
and and their and and they publish fake
garbage
so all
you know look
i all i want is i i told newsguard right
off the bat how could you deem us
irresponsible but have a lower standard
than us and they just said too bad so
sad go cry about it
send me that effect we may we we make
our judgments based on the fact that
we're looking for you to correct these
articles without us coming to you for
them and i said we've corrected
substantial articles without you coming
to us and telling us to correct them you
found five articles that you had
questions on only one of which had a
factual inaccuracy which we corrected
right away as per our corrections policy
it's arbitrary there is no objective
standard and right now newsguard is
falsely claiming that we publish
misleading information why because we
quoted the president
we quoted donald trump in a news story
and they said that that qualifies us for
publishing misleading content so when
usa today or the new york times quotes
donald trump are they not publishing
misleading content the argument is
trump's quotes are misleading right
why is it only when we do it great i
want them to answer to a judge why it is
the new york times can publish the exact
same thing as us
in terms of the reporting and the quotes
and that's responsible but for us it's
not it's because i think
there may be a motive that is more
attuned to causing harm intentional
injury and monetary damages to small
small businesses that might compete with
the friends of these organizations and
their investors yeah anybody who tries
to create a new media company anybody
who tries to to report news that falls
outside of the official cathedral
narrative for some reason has a really
rough go of it
so i'll tell you this
in the newsroom as hannah claire can
attest to i've been extremely adamant
about abiding by every one of
newsguard's policies
because i wanted to see that if we went
above and beyond and at everything they
deemed to be correct would they would
they honor that and they did not because
they are fake
and now i want them to answer in court
if they refuse so i told them
that uh i've i've talked i've already
forwarded my my demands to their general
counsel
and
you better believe we are going to
file a suit and if in the end they
respond and they say it's protected
opinion
fine so be it they get to explain why
their standards are lower than ours oh
and they get to rate us dude i'm looking
at some of news guards investors right
now one of them is blue haven initiative
which is
according to pitchbook.com is an impact
investor and if you don't know what
those are you should look into it impact
investing is specifically social
engineering it's it's from
investopedia.com investors who use
impact investing as a strategy
mis consider a company's commitment to
corporate social responsibility or the
sense of duty to positively serve
society so they have an agenda they're
they're one of their this is one of
their i don't know if it's a top
investor but maybe it's alphabetical but
they they certainly if they're impact
investing that is specifically with an
agenda to get the company to do
something the funny thing is
two of the articles were us just quoting
trump we were like donald trump says you
know you know it's like that was it like
donald trump came out he issued a
response and like in response to joe
biden trump says quote
and they said you should have included
context saying that trump was wrong and
i said well that would be a fact check
article we're just reporting trump
issued a statement right and he was like
well that's irresponsible because
trump's comments are wrong
and so
you know this is this is where i was
getting to with
we would have to fact check every single
quote but they didn't tell us to
fact-check anything biden said when
biden was wrong only trump
clearly
what they're actually trying to do is
manipulate our editorial guidelines and
standards
and so i said like are you telling us
that order to be responsible we have to
adhere to your editorial policy and then
they're like no no no we're not saying
anything like that but yes
but you only have to fact check donald
trump
only donald trump and you better do it
he took no issue with any other quotes
what blue haven initiative wants
otherwise they'll pull their impact
investment out of newsguard which is to
you know what what bluehaven uh
initiative wants is to
uh generate a measurable beneficial
social or environmental impact alongside
financial return i wonder what their
social impact they're trying to acquire
yep
let's find out the institutions are as
corrupt as corrupt can be
so
people people again you need to
understand what their goal here is is to
go to advertising agencies and say
anybody we deem unworthy do not sell
with they're unsafe and it's happened to
a lot of people so when you get
when when newsguard goes after you
like
unless you're operating in in the
parallel economy which is what a lot of
people are trying to do
then you're going to be cut off from
financial resources and that's their
their goal it is cancel culture on crack
on steroids
so this is one of the most important
fronts now i will say this and i'm very
proud to say this uh
msnbc is officially fake news according
to newsguard so look
i think newsguard does some good i just
think they're biased and the machine is
broken
we are actually you know looking at how
we can do a different kind of writing on
journalistic ethics so i think there
does need to be
some kind of system that says like here
are things this company has done the
problem is
newsguard violates their own standards
and and publishes false information and
then accuses other people of doing the
same thing that being said when an
organization is broken and biased as
this calls msnbc
violating severe journalistic standards
that's still good news because when the
machine itself is rejecting its own
garbage you can take this from newsguard
and you can show all your friends and
family when they claim msnbc is real
there you go at least something right
yeah good for something yeah um
this might be an interesting segue to
the berry rice thing with chocolate oh
let's pull up the barry weiss thing yeah
let's talk all about how the corrupt
media operates
daily mail reports
barry weiss reveals new york times
editors wanted to check with chuck
schumer before running an op-ed by
republican tim scott about his police
reform bill after george floyd's murder
what
it's amazing tim scott had a police
reform bill and the democrats said no to
it and the new york times wanted to
check with chuck schumer that's what
barry wei says former nyt opinion editor
barry weiss told senator tim scott on
wednesday about an internal discussion
around his op-ed
scott's article was the subject of an
internal debate excuse me why said and
one of the senior editors questioned
whether republicans cared about minority
rights
the new york times denied her account
saying the new york times opinion never
seeks outside approval or consultation
whether to publish guest opinion essays
i'm going to call bs in the new york
times having worked for many of these
you know organizations this is the exact
kind of stuff you see yep absolute
corruption
yep
and also
barry is
actually trustworthy
yeah she's been doing pretty well with
her substick yeah i trust her way more i
think she gets some things wrong you
know but that's fine i think she's more
trustworthy in her assessments than the
new york times and she's also just
telling
a rendition of something she witnessed
she's credible yes incredible witness
um she has no reason to make this up
she's you know she's moved on from the
new york times she's very successful
she's making more money than she did
well reason she could make it up is to
get back at them for something
but why not say it sooner
i mean
i don't know i'm not very wise
but
i think more people should speak out
about the stuff sooner rather than later
and she mentioned it was in 2020 but
she's been independent for a long time
so why not
say something sooner
i know it's quite the hat trick you're
gonna have to have her on the show and
ask her about it it's topical and i'm
not saying that she's lying i'm just
saying that you know i wonder too if
they're sorry oh no go for it there's a
lot of stuff she could probably say you
can't you know you if you publish your
memoir the day you leave or you know in
2020 stuff is going to get missed like
in some ways
i didn't read this article so i can't
say what the context like
where she brought it up um
but
i have a conversation with tim scott
right and i
feel like
there was a lot of stuff she could tell
us about what happened there
if she doled it all at once i think it
would get kind of lost the impact would
get lost yeah i mean i from from the
reporting she was having a conversation
with tim scott and she said
i i don't know if you know this but
there this is what happened and so i
think it was sort of a natural thing i
mean it makes me wonder what other
stories she has under her hat and i
think that there was a lot of i mean she
was i think she should have sued the new
york times personally because it was you
know workplace bullying and intimidation
and everything and
um i think that there was some stuff
that happened that in the moment she
felt like she was crazy because every
everyone was like well yes of course we
talked to chuck schumer about it we just
wanted to clear it and she's kind of
like but why do we clearly chuck schumer
what and i think
it's you know you're as you exit the
cult she's kind of like i was really
messed up wasn't it and she's kind of
having that realization and sort of
unpacking her own experience because i
think she was so abused
you ever see uh bullworth that movie no
you ever see it no kevin kahn no no
that's uh what's it warm beatty i think
it's the one where uh the politician the
senator is like super depressed and
wants to kill himself so then he just
starts telling the truth and like he
doesn't care anymore but then he like
decides he wants to live or whatever
he like goes up on stage at a black
church and they're like why didn't you
deliver this bill and he's like because
we got your vote we don't care the
moment you went voted for us we stopped
caring about what you thought and then
they were like what and then people
ended up really liking it
i think that with you know people like
barry weiss
she's probably sitting on a whole bunch
of other stuff and i'd say like come on
like of course she is that she's not
going to talk about because she's
probably scared about what will happen
if she if she challenges the machine
and
i mean if you were in a cult you
participated in the cult right so there
are there's probably stuff that she's i
could imagine not proud of or not ready
to talk about her involvement in right
and i
you know i don't necessarily hold that
against her it's a complicated thing to
come out of something or to disassociate
or something from an ideology you've
been wrapped up in for a long time but
some of her stories you know she's in
the rooms for a reason she's involved
with the organization so i mean she was
a junior staffer i mean i think i think
that um
i think it's it's hard to
to be in that moment i mean she was she
was in that newsroom and everyone around
her was just
they i mean they wanted to throttle her
and i i can't imagine what that feels
like to go
day after day somewhere where everyone
hates you
and one misstep like you didn't wash
your hands after you left the bathroom
can be become like a viral twitter
thread of your colleague who's sitting
like our distance apart from each other
um but i don't know if she's scared of
them anymore i think that she's burned
that bridge and she's not looking back
didn't uh someone who works with her
write that uh terrible article about
jordan peterson and enforced monogamy so
you wondered like to what degree they
were participating in the decision like
i don't want to do this
i don't i don't necessarily trust a lot
of people especially if it takes them
two years to come out and be like oh by
the way this like crazy this really
crazy thing happened it's like that's
that's the kind of thing where i'd be
like i want to quit and in fact when i
worked for fusion and they started doing
this stuff i tried quitting but i was
under contract so instead i just stopped
participating in in their in their bs
system
and then immediately started telling
everybody about it just like screaming
it and they really don't like it
the fact that they would stealth edit
articles and told me not to report on
the new york times doing stealth editing
because they would get exposed for doing
it as well and i was like i'm gonna tell
everybody are you nuts you mean you're
violating journalistic standards you
think i'm gonna keep that a secret bro
i'm a journalist like my goal is to
inform people not
not be like a tribalist for some
corporation you think i care about
fusion's bottom line like i'm here to
tell people what's going on in the world
so when the president of that company
said we're here to side with the
audience in reference to
how we handle bias and perspective
basically said you know millennial or he
said young people are progressive so
that's who we're going to side with
we're going to side with them
and when i said if if that does that
mean that does that mean if there's a
fact-based news story that would offend
our audience we don't report it he says
yeah i think that's fair and i
immediately told everybody
and then he denied it and i'm like
whatever man of course they're going to
deny it like these people aren't
journalists they're businessmen who are
like how do we make money
say what people want to hear
there are a lot of people working for
these organizations who know it james
o'keefe the the man is doing the lord's
work when he exposed cnn and you can see
these people saying like we used to do
the news now we don't those people
aren't speaking out those people aren't
coming out and explaining everybody
they're lying to their faces but behind
the scenes they're saying in private it
takes a special kind of person to know
you are engaged in operating an evil
machine that destroys this country but
be like
i need the paycheck
i don't know if that's it i mean i think
for i like speaking up for barry
like i'm not gonna speak up for the rest
of them but
i mean she and i had this experience as
someone who wrote for berry for the new
york times she fought really hard to get
sanity on the pages and to get
different perspectives published in the
times that wouldn't have otherwise been
there and i think that she swallowed
a lot of stuff for a long time that made
her deeply uncomfortable because she
felt like it was for the greater good
and i think she got to a point where she
realized
that is that is a calculus that no
longer
it's not it's not equaling out anymore
i'm not doing more good inside the
machine than outside the machine i think
that that's when she left but she fought
very hard
for a while to to operate under you know
behind enemy lines and i think it just
got to the point where she realized like
it just wasn't tangible anymore and she
wasn't having enough of an impact to
justify
not just you know being part of the
machine but also just the mental health
strain that she was under and the
assault that she was under by all of her
colleagues but
i respect her first gang as long as she
did but i mean there's people at cnn
that james o'keefe exposed yeah they're
like talking to this hidden camera
saying
look at all the really awful things this
company does and they're still there
and they just they they know
that's the craziest thing to me these
people are caught on camera talking
about how they know they're involved in
malfeasance
but i think they think it's for the
greater good no no no no they're telling
hidden camera like cnn is destroying
everything
and we are helping them and then they're
like but we're gonna stay but i think
they think ultimately it is for the
greater good because
they are
setting a narrative that how do they
think is important to how do you change
i no i'm saying
undercover camera exposes they're
admitting they're doing wrong are you
saying it's sort of like they're
accelerationists they're like look we
gotta burn it down and we are willing to
bring it down in this way
no like there's one famous guy who's
like sitting in a chair and he's like or
one of the famous exposes the guy was
like we used to go out and report the
news man now all we do is just complain
about trump and just try and drive this
this this and he thinks that's a good
but i think they think that's a good
thing and he's complaining about it and
he said he hates being i think it's
annoying but ultimately i think that
given the choice between straight
news reporting and trashing trump they
don't but this is a guy who's saying he
wished they did real news reporting i
think he says he i think he wants to say
that i think he but obviously he doesn't
actually believe it or he would right
left right well that's einstein said
that's the definition of an insanity is
when you keep doing the same thing
expecting a different result and these
people that are staying there expecting
it if they really are they believe it's
going to get better by staying there
they're insane according to einstein
it's a very general term but it could be
a form of insanity i don't think that's
a pass to do it i think
explanation of why i agree with you in
that regard that a lot of people say
they want things but they really don't
like they they either don't want it or
they actually just don't care enough to
pursue
going after something
so maybe for a lot of these people they
just think
you know this cnn's culture behind the
scenes is to rag on the company for
being garbage but no one really cares i
mean but also where do they go like in
their industry i mean it's it's kind of
like you know
great sort of all the complaints that
you hear about parents of kids in
private schools and they complain and
they complain and complain i'm thinking
of the sort of the folks that are
talking about like the wokeness in in
all these private schools
and
they stay because it's the pinnacle of
achievement and i think that these
people at cnn this is the pinnacle of
professional achievement in their
industry and so where do they go what do
they do there's no next step and so
they're just sort of stuck in a holding
pattern because they care more about
their job
that's my point though they care more
about their their
personal lives than they do about the
system they're participating in yeah i
mean not just but i don't think it's
just the paycheck i think it's also
their pride i think it's
i think it's a lot of their sort of
self-identity and they would rather be
you know that's probably why they
demoted taylor lorenz the behind the
scenes uh scuttlebutt was that long-time
staffers were losing their minds
complaining that she was like
besmirching the organization and
charging his name
oh absolutely pr for that company yeah
and they thought the controversy was
going to generate traffic or so this is
what i heard this from someone who you
know
had like behind the scenes access or
something like that
this is at washington post yeah okay
that the the long-standing employees of
the washington post like the older
people were like you are destroying the
legacy of this company
and that apparently there are people
there who thought that taylor lorenz was
going to generate traffic through like
controversy or stuff like that i don't
want to say anything that's confirmed
it's just rumor mill stuff i've heard
the same rumors right so they're they're
like they're
journalists who and so i i wonder if the
washington post was like
these people are going to quit on us and
then we have nothing so we got to do
something
and so they demoted taylor lorenz and i
mean i think it i think i don't think
that's why they i think that they just
decided that she was a liability yeah i
think she should be careful
she was a liability people were like
there was a risk to the company i don't
think it was that it was a risk that
come i just think that they realized
that that's what a liability is no no i
think that they realize that
she has no loyalty and that any any
controversy that she conjures
it's
often going to be at their expense
because she doesn't care about the brand
she just cares about herself and so
i don't think that they were worried
that people were going to quit i think
they were worried that
they that she was a beast that was about
to turn on them someone told me that
when we put up the billboard in times
square saying she doxed libs of tik tok
that she immediately went and demanded
they file a suit or something and like
file a legal thing to get taken down and
they were like it's an opinion statement
you can't do anything about it and she
like lost it and then she went on
twitter and said it was so stupid and
laughable and then i responded with like
i responded to her and i was like i'm
glad you like i'm glad you think it's
funny great you got to say your thing i
say my thing and then she lost it she
blocked me and started screaming like
it's violence or whatever and i'm like
okay dude
whatever man
someone uh pointed out to me that
timcast.com has a higher credibility
rating than cnn.com yeah that's amazing
that's true
that is in fact true look at that that's
kind of funny cnn's garbage so imagine
what we'd have
if other stuff wasn't going on i mean
the vibe that media companies are like
pr companies like that news
organizations have tended towards public
relations like that the news they
produce is a form of pr
the news the medium is the message and
so they're just trying to keep the way
they look about presenting the news
palatable for the masses as opposed to
just directly reporting the information
and so that's why they have spin doctors
and things like that
it's a little concerning
well our standards at timcast.com are
extremely rigorous and we have like
conversations over how we how we frame
things even we don't just fact check we
frame check so we've had a conversation
about do we say pro-life or pro-choice
we say neither only in the context of
when it like is truly explaining the
circumstance but if someone comes out
and says we demand access to abortion
that is pro-abortion we don't need to
say anything else it's not about choices
it's just about whether you're for
nobody goes to a rally and says like we
think people should be able to choose
their own meals choose their own birth
birthdays i'm like okay choice is a
political term life is a political term
are you against abortion or for abortion
of course the pro-life people agree and
they're like that's fine i get it we're
against abortion the pro-choice people
lose their minds we are not pro-abortion
stop saying that and i'm like dude we
are not going to editorialize this let's
go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com because
we got some stories for you coming up on
the after hours show man i'll just tell
you like
boston children's hospital
hysterectomies on children oh my gosh
yeah we'll talk about that because this
is this is
the way she delivered it too i'm looking
for it's crazy she's like laughing and
smiling it's choker level stuff man
anyway let's read some super chats from
uh from from all of y'all all of y'all
oh here's one james eaton says static
i really like static shock he's a great
superhero you ever watched that show or
read that comic
no static shock they should do a warner
brothers movie for static that'd be
that'd be legit i totally watch it
anyway i had no idea what he was trying
to say was he talking to like talking
about the the audio maybe maybe i like
it better that he's just like trying to
get your opinion on a superhero comic
book
all right
can't uh contencaro says tim you keep
mentioning picnicking at the battle of
fort sumter
and you are confusing it with the first
battle of bull run july 21 1861 which
was the first land battle of the civil
war uh perhaps you are correct i was
reading an article online when they
mentioned the king picnicking and they
may have um
i may have misinterpreted what they were
saying it was i was reading a historical
article and it was like when the battle
of fort sumter which started the civil
war or whatever people were so in
disbelief they were picking up on the
hillside and i may have assumed it was
the same same thing but uh you wanna
yeah the first thing i type picnic
battle of and the thing that first thing
came up was was the first battle of bull
run really the picnic battle ah okay
well there you go thank you
for the correction
i will make sure to apply it to all of
my analogies moving forward
all right
let's see
david c says from last night does ian
understand that our politicians are like
this because they aren't investigated
all of them should fear investigation
and prosecution
um
geez i i mean
there's so many reasons why people in
control of the military and the power
are doing what they're doing i i think
maybe part of it is that they feel like
as long as they're in that position that
they won't be investigated for doing
what we've basically asked them to do
behind our backs which is control the
military i mean the amount of bombings
and stuff that's going on in the world
right now with our eyes blind to it is
is
it's it's it's nuts it's nuts you know
um we could talk more about that too i
was talking about forgiveness i feel
like a lot of this
is like
the air like you were saying about barry
weiss that maybe she feels guilty about
what she had done while she was part of
the cult and like maybe she said the
n-word and it's gonna come out in 2017
at a meeting and like just let it go man
let all this past crap go so we can
focus on right now
and the future
all right jay says while i can't help
being nervous i'm still hopeful i had to
remind myself to breathe slow down and
reset your thoughts we will defeat the
authoritarians right ian
uh that is one way to look at it yes you
slow down to speed up it's like getting
traction with a wheel on a road if it
spins too fast it's not gonna go
anywhere
all right a bunch of super chat saying
that ian and my mics aren't working they
were working so the issue was that we
turned up bethany because she was really
quiet at first and then she was picking
up echo from the room so i muted the
purple mic and turned yours down and
everything well there you go yeah solved
it
beavis mclean says check out executive
order one three two nine two section one
three classification authority clearly
states authority to classify information
may be exercised by the president in
performance of executive duties this
includes the declassification as well
love you ian crossland oh i love you too
what was that that executive order
number do you have that again one three
two nine two section 1.3
brandi green says ian thank you for the
tip on differentiating the good
weinstein brothers is it weinstein
weinsteins like einstein those are the
good guys weinstein brothers by rhyming
oh it's right there i should've read it
yeah rhyming with einstein
p.s i'm a
s-a-h-m what is that
stay-at-home mom and watch tim cast in
pop culture crisis with my 22 month old
daily here's to a based homeschool
education that's awesome here
i'm
at their babies after
school culture show that's amazing i
better learn all about johnny depp
oh
not that yeah i had the honor of meeting
a uh a local politician in west virginia
recently and we're in discussions about
i'm going to be helping fund a micro
school
which uh believes in the traditional
american values
and they do have a bible study but i'm
told it's optional for parents who just
want to get away from the woke stuff but
i dig it micro school so it's going to
be very small classrooms
it's basically like the next level up
after homeschooling like private tutors
but in a bigger setting so i
i am i am uh
absolutely trying to make sure we are
putting our money where our mouths are
through schooling that's it it was legit
like when i heard what they were talking
about the way they want to handle stuff
is brilliant instead of having like
grades you have grade subjects so like
your third grade math and seventh grade
reading and then they just work with you
where you that's what we do i homeschool
my kids and that's that's exactly
it's so great it was one of the worst
things about the hope scholarship issues
that west virginia is having is that it
took away a lot of choice that parents
had to opt into other education um the
hope scholarship is like
a program in west virginia that would
give money if you decide to pull your
kid out of public school and choose an
alternative route so you could put it
towards all kinds of things and uh it
got rejected by a
judge in the state and that is
a real blow to uh school choice in my
opinion virginia
e rodriguez says i'm catching up on one
and a half playback speed and tim is
bordering on a rap god levels of words
per minute
that's it
some like i mentioned this before like
when i'm doing segments on my other
channels
i'll be like i'll have so much going on
with work that i'm like i got to get
this done fast but the segments are are
timed not word count so i'll start
talking really fast and end up turning a
20 minute segment into a double-timed
40-minute segment because i'll say dude
i put on one of our shows about last
week at two two times speed and was
listening to you and i could it was so
fast but i could understand every word
you were saying because of your
enunciation yeah you have incredible
enunciation i don't think you get enough
credit for that i don't know do i it was
funny
it was extremely clear the way you speak
about the headlines yeah
yes that's my that means that was a good
interpreter that was a good what's the
word i listen to personal impersonation
delhi says has the fbi done anything
good recently
it's tough it's tough to tell because
they do a lot of stuff in secret i mean
they did deal with the mob
pretty handedly i i um i don't know what
they're doing with the cartels i feel
like we could say they did this thing
right and then i'd be like ruby ridge
and you'd be like but they did this
thing right i'd be like boycott and then
yeah
do you remember ed and elaine brown
i think luke knew knew these people they
they were as 2007 i think they were they
weren't paying their income tax and so
they had like 100 acre property in new
hampshire and just said nope and the
feds had to come in but they were really
scared that they were going to get
another waco or ruby ridge with like
these people and then they realized they
said
that these these these tax abolitionist
people were
letting supporters in so they just put
on plain clothes came up and knocked in
the door and said they were supporters
got led in and then arrested them and
that was like the end of it
yeah i looked at the uh the irs job
hiring thing for these new 80 000 people
did you see some of the requirements
they're like just so you know you got to
be ready to work 50 hours a week use our
weapons against people if it comes up we
should pull that out that was
specifically the criminal investigation
division of the irs which has been
around since 1919. uh-huh so like if you
didn't pay some tax it really it looks
like a tax model that they're trying to
put so
this is crazy because i'm seeing so many
people mischaracterize what's going on
like i don't like the irs dude like come
on who does
and i don't think there should be 87 000
new irs agents but i'm seeing people be
like democrats want to hire 87 000 new
irs agents who are authorized to use
deadly force they're building an army
and i'm like no they are hiring criminal
investigation division because the irs
has a law enforcement section
but they're not hiring 87 000 dudes with
guns right they've
like there's images of the irs police
they have badges it says police they
wear armor it says police so it's been
normalized just so everyone knows well
yeah for a hundred years and what they
what they claim to particularly go after
is like if there's uh
like al capone style stuff yeah mobsters
who are doing money laundering schemes
and things like that the irs sends in
the criminal enforcement division to go
after them i think people just didn't
know that existed and so
now they're freaking out totally free
rightly so
all right what is this waffle sensei
says tim are you gonna repeat your
deleted tweet from today on the after
show repeat it delete a tweet
did you delete a tweet repeat delete
which one oh the one that i had to i
don't know i don't know what you're
referring to
the one that they made me get rid of
today no when they when they locked my
account do you ever tweet stuff out and
then remove it only if there's a typo
yeah i do that too oh actually yeah
there's probably been a couple instances
like where i make a mistake or something
i was gonna post one last night i just
left it on the screen unpublished and
then i went to the sauna it was two
nights ago and i'm like if i still want
to put it up out of the sauna then i'll
put it up because i couldn't decide some
things don't work in text you got to say
them i feel like i don't have the
personality for twitter i don't know
what what you need to be
good at it and i appreciate people who
are good but like i just feel like i'm
not cut out for that world i'm just
you you have to be like really really
just brutal
and very pithy and i feel like i i am
good at those things
jeb reed says fact the u.s has already
fallen republic is no longer the
cornerstones of this country are
shattered the next phase is mass attacks
on
just say regular people
insinuating the government will be doing
it um
there was an article today
that referred to the gadsden flag as far
right extremism
when your own country's history is
labeled by the corporate press by the
institutions as extremism
it kind of feels like your country is
being worn like a skin suit
uh you know
well there was that new yorker cover
of the republican
house and the democratic house yes and
the republican house had an american
flag yeah
i remember that yeah it was a it was a
really um
that
surprisingly insightful and striking
cover actually it was and that cover did
not get enough attention no it does the
left wing house was warm and open well
manicured green lawn pride flag black
lives matter no american flag yeah it
really hold down it yeah it's hold on
itself
i mean we we get so
at heroes of liberty we publish books
about you know
alexander hamilton ronald reagan and we
tried to run ads on twitter about our
books
in the wake of
roe v wade and we were sort of
advertising like faith and freedom
whatever we never said anything about
dobbs nothing and twitter throttled us
and that i mean like facebook throttled
us also right in the very beginning like
this idea that patriotism
is somehow political
is i mean we've been told that directly
by these social media companies yeah
it's a global technocracy jeff
jeff was who made that last comment
right i want to make sure um i don't
know don't be too black-pilled man
uh
you know
you got neighbors ryan hunter says i
think my biggest fear about the future
where uh future we're staring down is
the idea that a u.s civil conflict gets
to a point where foreign entities like
china and or russia can recognize our
breakaways
yeah last night i was like we do not
want to fight each other if people start
fighting each other not only if you
advocate for that you've lost the plot
you do not want that that outside
governments will fund people to fight
don't want that crap that's that's how
it was in the revolution that's how it
was in the civil war i think that's
what's happening now i mean i think
tick-tock is that yeah i think that
tick-tock is fomenting and
throwing accelerant on the fires that we
already have going
but what will end up happening in a
civil war is china's going to go to west
coast states and say what do you need to
win yes yes that's what we've got to
avoid is is that kind of thing could you
imagine like the year is 21 37
and like too far in advance the united
states of the chinese communist party
are like going over history and they
were like when the revolution started it
was thanks to chinese intervention and
they make movies called like there's
like a new movie called the patriot
and like a chinese general lands in
california is like i will help you win
in san francisco yeah and san francisco
we used to not have trans-pacific
magnetic trains before we were one
country
trans united states of china yeah
all right all right let's get some more
super chats
akapot says reappropriate a portion of
the fbi's budget to be grants to the
state's bureaus of investigation instead
then we'll see if they can still afford
to fund partisanship in their budget
i think the fbi is important i do
interstate crime is an issue and dealing
with it
is something we need to do the problem
is i don't feel like anyone has
confidence in the institution at this
point so that something's got to change
otherwise
people are just going to get angry and
angrier and then you'll get crazy stuff
like what we saw today which we
definitely do not want we could have a
fbi agent on the show someday i think
probably yeah cool well we didn't we
have something like foreign we've had
some people who are former folks working
in that field yeah it's interesting
there's a lot in this area
mike roman says make dan bongino head of
the fbi
okay can we no dan fun technically do it
so that's right is it possible he has
experience in that field jim comey can
do it who yeah the sky's the limit
exactly
john kersten says there's no need for
the fbi when they serve practically the
same function as the u.s marshals
that's interesting yeah i hear that
but do the marshals do the investigatory
work and things like that yeah they do
or i don't think they do yeah i think
they just do arrests
yeah i like watching those old westerns
where the marshal would go out to
collect a bounty or something like that
those are fun just watched a little
young guns last night there you go
matthew jamieson says the cia was doing
mk ultra by fines paid to citizens of
canada klaus schwab's assistant says
humans are hackable would the gov
would the gov to do this
yes
okay yes
i don't know waffle sensei says hey bro
can i get an update on the album i need
some sick beats to kick at work you know
i don't think we're doing an album i
think we're doing an album but we're
just releasing the singles because we
talked about it and like
it's not really the way they don't no
one really does it anymore where they
just put out an album and so we've got a
song planned for release in 10 days
10 days bro that's great i'm so excited
i heard you playing a couple songs
earlier i was singing along with them
dude i'm really stoked on uh
the
people are going to be confused by
whatever this band is no one's gonna be
able to define it yeah it was like
there's this one song that i really like
a million to one it's like uh don't stop
believing by journey but it's kind of
like the foo fighters
i think it's way too simple to be
described like that yeah like it's like
got that like uplifting like kind of
vague inspirational feel like don't stop
believing that's what i got poppy it's
real pop we've got one song that's like
discordant electro
with guitar and like electric drums
that has like weird voice modulation
it's a really trippy song and then like
the first song we're putting out is very
just like pop
like with like rock in the end
i don't know it's all over the place
because i don't like bands where it's
like they write one song and then copy
it seven times and release an album
yeah well i like it when you're like
that's the same band
that's what i'm looking for oh yeah
people are going to be like they're the
first they're going to say there's no
way that's tim's singing then they're
going to say is this this is this still
tim because it's like it's all very
different is that tim and it'll be me
that's the funny thing like we have a
song out already called will of the
people and like half the comments are
like is this really tim singing it's
like we used to play it you can google
it you can just like watch me sing on
the show yeah friday nights not that i
was singing very well back then because
it's like you can't record 16 hours a
day you know work 16 hours a day and
then try and sing at the at the end of
it but
while uh
eric miller says i watched your bit
about monsters inc is it just me or is
it a mockery of mainstream media i.e
scared children as frightened viewers
that's actually a fair point yeah we
were talking uh mary said that isn't
monsters inc like adrenochrome
like scaring the kids and then using
that to fuel their machines or whatever
actually it's a really good point about
the media
freaking out and screaming in people's
faces to get them all scared so they can
power their machines
there you go man what a creepy world
that we live in but adrenochrome for the
record is uh oxidized adrenaline if
anyone uh yeah and people believe really
weird things about it for some reason
matt burkhart says please keep hannah
claire as a full-time member of the show
she is definitely my favorite she rocks
after tim of course well you know hey
that didn't say that did it does it does
say that
you heard it from them first you're
great on this show i love your
information oh gosh thanks for having me
on it's uh it was always weird because i
would watch the show downstairs and be
like i don't even think i could talk
this much i couldn't talk for this long
no she was down there like i could talk
better than oh well i practice my
enunciations like
unique new york i'm so grateful to be
here it's been fun how now brown cow
cubicle investor says ian last night you
said government-level crimes should be
pardoned what message does that send
minorities during time for far less
egregious crimes
that would just further solidify class
issues yeah i'm open to a mass pardon
and i don't know i don't think it should
have to stop at any one spot i i think
just
what's that you would you would pardon
everybody well i don't know if
everybody's the right word but i'm
talking like 150 years of nonsense we've
been at it right we've been at each
other's throats anarchy
yes everyone's but i don't advocate for
like turning the other way for
ongoing crime or for future crime i'm
not talking about that what about
violent crimes yeah violent crimes is
kind of off the table i don't i'm not
really into pardoning violence okay
i just feel like that's a good when you
when you give that spiel you should you
should that you're gonna be like let
everyone out but like when someone
orders a drone strike is that a
non-violent crime
so here's another question what about
a
dealer who knowingly was distributing
fentanyl laced drugs and getting kids
hooked on them that died yeah exactly is
that violence
would you pardon them because drug i
mean
well let's think about it i can't do
this alone it's it's got a long
conversation we should have all right
powder pz says my dog killed one of my
chickens today rest in peace drumstick
oh you will be messed up
uh if you watch chicken city we're
talking about who we're going to eat
first oh no
yeah so they should start eating them
things like that like your chicken
tenders yeah people do that drumstick
and tender why don't you put it to a
casual yeah i feel like it would be
hunger games but chicken style we're not
gonna eat any that have names
but we but like 70 percent have no names
what if you just like take mug shots of
them and then just put it up for a vote
i think we should actually uh criminally
charge them
so roberto for instance he was sent to
we call it cocktown
there's 18 roosters there oh my gosh
yeah now what most people out here do is
they say you let nature have them like
you just let them do their thing go off
and then maybe a fox will eat them or
something right but uh some of the
people here did not find that appealing
and i'm like well if we don't let them
go we're gonna eat them
but you know roosters are tough they're
like rubbery you gotta you gotta slow
cook them and get it going if you want
to you know get it right
but um roberto
he abused one of the uh did one of the
hens he's terry dorothy yeah dorothy and
uh so
initially we had to lock dorothy away
because she was getting hurt you know
getting hurt and then people complained
and said why are you why are you
punishing the victim and i said good
point roberto has been sentenced to his
cr for his crimes and he has been sent
to a penal colony you banished him yes
banished he is so it's funny because we
have um
three really big black star roosters
which are bullies
and so we we have a chicken we have a
coop
and then in it are all the smaller
roosters and then roberto's in charge
because he was the biggest and oldest
but the three black star boys were just
they would gang up and spin around them
so we have them with an electrified
fence outside the coop and it looks like
they're prison guards actually kind of
funny and they jump on top of it and
they they crap all over the place one of
them apparently jumped out and tried
getting away but we were like
you just let them go go ahead we're not
gonna
actually you want to go to nature i mean
how could you stop them right yeah yeah
but we can have mock trials for the ones
we're going to eat
we can walk in and be like come here
everybody come here and the one that
doesn't come is the one that gets eaten
so we get to keep the personable ones
harsh oh
jmk says joe rogan said in his podcast
today that he thought tim poole was
crazy for thinking a civil war was
coming and now he believes tim may be
right i'll listen to that did he really
don't know because i because i
yeah i should someone uh can someone
tweet that to you would you be able to
see it sure yeah tag me in it or
something yeah tag ian ian crossland
right on twitter tag ian if you saw that
clip because um i got to tell you in it
was 2019 i think when i went on rogan
with with twitter and i said at the end
of it that if twitter kept doing what
they were what they were doing with
censorship it was going to lead to like
civil chaos or conflict or something and
i was like that's why i'm building a van
like a building a van with all this
equipment in it and like solar power
because
yo i'm i'm looking at what's going on
and you know honestly i knew people
would think that was crazy that i would
say something like that i'm gonna build
a van and go live down by the river
they're gonna be this dude's office
rocker and i wasn't i look
i just say i don't know exactly what's
gonna happen
but you look at where we are now and if
you don't think we are in the midst of
historical tumult then you are a frog
boiling in a pot can you when did you
say that 2019 in 2018 i said a civil war
was coming on 2019 i was on rogan when i
said if twitter keeps doing this it
doesn't seem so crazy after 2020
when there was armed guards outside
costco and i had to buy freaking diapers
like and then we had a formula shortage
the next year i think that our trust in
the stability of our civilization
is sufficiently rocked by everything we
saw in 2020 that i don't think people
would think you were crazy saying that
now i think the writing's been on the
walls for some people who pay a lot of
attention to news and cultural shifts
for a long time but
people don't want to hear it because
they can't conceptualize what a civil
war would look like that's like even now
with everything that's going on with you
know a recent attack on an fbi building
there's this question of like is it is
it starting is this it is is this is
this what we've been talking about yeah
i said before the show oh are you gonna
say oh i was just gonna joke that my
contractor thinks i'm crazy because i
have a nice stockpile of food and
diapers good before the show i was like
no tim i don't think it's civil war and
he was like civil and i was like you
know what this is semantic it doesn't
matter what we call it we're all aware
of what's this this chaos whether or not
i think it's global i think for sure
that's
undisputable at this point that there's
global corporate
but it really doesn't matter how you
term the thing the chaos is real the
chaos is apparent i believe
man
raymond g stanley jr says roberto jr is
the second best junior
so we got roberto jr on this billboard
in times square advertising chicken city
and my favorite comment was roberto jr
is sitting atop a throne he did not
create
because roberto was the boss for a while
but the thing is roberto's mean
roberto is a a pretty mean guy
and uh roberto's really nice
like when you walk in roberto would like
come at you but roberto jr would just
like look at you and he like does his
thing and then they flaps his wings then
walks around but it's probably because
we raised roberto jr from when he
hatched right and you know and then
roberto we bought roberto's like a great
warrior with low intelligence as a
leader like you don't really want that
guy as your leader
he but he was the first one it was like
alexander the great's father uh what was
his name the
the first macedonian
something of macedon philip he looks
around we're like philip someone knows
you'll get this from philip of macedon
he was i mean he was also extremely
intelligent charismatic but not like
alex i think part of it is like roberto
had a different set of circumstances he
had to kind of uh
make his way through life it was a much
harder time and now you know he has
given his son this kingdom to rule and
it's you know it requires a different
set of skills he's doing a good job
actually roberto junior is a good dude
yeah he makes good music matt giesey
says you guys are uh you guys remember
when alec baldwin shot someone pepperage
farmer
if someone's gonna play james comey in a
movie it's alec baldwin because last
time i watched a video about him they
like people in movies at all you know oh
that's true i feel like you shoot
someone on set yeah i don't know that we
like bring you back on right maybe
that's a good point he needs 10 years
off i mean the insurance premiums alone
i feel like oh my gosh
mike the dad crosby says oh on twitter
it appears trump stole the nuclear codes
i hope they can change them now and
since it's too easy to guess four three
two one
is that what you're saying on twitter i
i think he stole
some aliens information i
i think i mean
they're out there i think he stole the
information wow you think he's talking
he's told information about talking
plasma
where they triangulate lasers and hit a
point in the sky or it shows up on radar
and they think it's a craft but they
just move around a dot i feel like i
just set out for the ian bat signal
let's talk about aliens
i said the other night zeta reticuli
wasn't real that i kind of
misinterpreted what i was thinking it
wasn't
aliens didn't really come from zeta
reticuli that's just what they told
literally 9.59 okay it is you did this
all right sparky says tim don't you
realize the feds are swatting you
why would i realize that why would the
feds be swatting me you know
i just i don't understand this kind of
like conspiracy logic i guess
what would be gained by swatting me
when it has zero impact on us we had a
credible threat
which uh did cause an evacuation but
that was the night 40 000 or less
yeah 40 000 people watched and then
jeremy hambly gave us a bunch of money
and so i was like it kind of sucks but
you make the best of it we learned that
chaircast was a viable option for the
business and also i need to stress that
um
the properties that are being targeted
are known specifically to a group of
people that we're aware of and so
evidence does not indicate there is
the feds coming after us to put it
simply i can't give out too much
information but
let me just say there's something called
coloring the water
where you have three cups on a table
and there's a pool of water under all of
them how do you figure out which cup is
leaking you put red in one green in one
and blue in the other and whatever color
the water on the table turns you know
where the leak is in the cup
to put it simply the people who are
coming to swattings have made a series
of errors in thinking that traps were
not set so
we'll see what happens but um at this
point considering what i know of the
investigation i can say that much
because the deeds have already been done
and that we've already ensnared enough
information we think so we'll see how it
goes we'll uh we'll see what happens
let's grab
let's grab a couple more what do we got
here we'll grab one more
tyler w says
to the gulag with you roberto i banish
you
you know i'm worried about roberto you
know i don't i don't want any harm to
befall him he's one of the original cast
members of chicken city but we just
can't have a dad banging his daughters
yeah that was the problem he went too
far well that's what they do chickens
you know so now we have uh it's funny we
have um his son isaac
who uh
is a brahma rhode island red mix and
he's massive
he's huge he's gonna be so big brahma
brahmas are so big
and so he's already
you know
he jumped on a hen today and the other
hands ran up and started pecking him to
stop him they were like get out of here
like
yeah good second wave feminism second
wave feminism for the chickens
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have
that uncensored episode coming up in
about an hour or so you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast bethany do you want to shout
anything out yeah bethany shandark on
twitter and instagram and
heroesofliberty.com for your children's
book needs and deseret.com for my other
thoughts we should get some of those
books for the school i was talking about
i was actually going to try to plug that
but i thought about it yeah oh yeah
right on cool i'm hannah claire i'm a
writer for timcast.com it's a very cool
news site i recommend you check it daily
uh you can follow me on instagram at
hannah claire.b i was on today's episode
of pop culture crisis so if you go to
youtube you can check that out and you
might see me a lot there next week
all right guys ian crossland you know
it's easy to get things wrong when you
talk a lot as your job in public so if
you ever say anything that's factually
inaccurate please tweet it at me um and
hit my app ian crossland on twitter or
on mines so that i can uh attempt to
correct the error on air live i like
what i did about zeta reticuli earlier
happy to be here always happy for the
opportunity bethany great to see you
again bye everyone thank you guys for
tuning in tonight with bethany we always
have a great time i'm loving the
presence of more ladies i feel like this
is definitely a trend i can get behind
you guys can follow me on twitter and
minds.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you